[Musique]
bonjour richard bartoli
bonjour monsieur viol tombe on jouera
tous les martiniquais bonjour à tous li
trinité le président la scène du galion
qui dansent arcady ce matin le galion
dans la tourmente car toute une filière
sucre mais également rome distillerie
des planteurs sont dans l'expectative
richard bartel herry pouvons nous dire
aujourd'hui qu'il y aura bel et bien une
campagne sucrière pour l'usiné
trinitéenne absolument tout sera fait
pour que la campagne sucrière 2018 soit
réalisée soit faite
vous savez très bien qu'il y a un gros
problème sur la chaudière on ne va pas
revenir forcément je suis toute la
problématique de la chaudière mais je
crois que tout sera fait pour qu'il y
ait une campagne sucrière en 2018
oui parce que le problème paul porte sur
cette chaudière qui alimente en énergie
l'usiné de production du sucre alors
trois options la première on achète une
nouvelle chaudière pour alimenter les
usines 20 millions sans fonds européens
avec des délais difficile à tenir en
termes de livraison on oublie ça s'est
fini c'est pas la peine de retenir cette
option non je ne peux pas répondre à
cette question maintenant pense tout
simplement parce que il y a plusieurs
options
il y à l'achat d'une chaudière neuve
entre 15 et 20 millions y compris le
génie civil qui va avec
il y a également le raccordement à la
centrale thermique albi au mas ou la
réparation la troisième option la
réparation de la chaudière à la leur
alors retour dans le jeu non justement
cette deuxième option la centrale
biomasse 270 millions d'euros
d'investissements privés pas d'argent
public une centrales polluantes mais
moins ce que ce qui existe le coût de
raccordement 7 millions d'euros à peu
près mais il ya deux obstacles
politiquement puisqu'on rappelle que la
majorité à la 7e dont vous faites partie
ne veut pas en entendre parler tout à
fait donc il faut être honnête tout le
tous les journalistes c'est vous-même et
les martiniquais sable très bien que la
majorité de ma majorité une majorité
n'était pas
n'était pas n'avait pas choisi cette
option de raccordement et avait on fait
une proposition de alternatif dans les
déviations vers nation à la chaudière
mais politiquement on n'en veut pas et
vous ne voulez surtout pas vous l'avez
rappelé lors d'une intervention en
plénière le dic le galion deviennent
dépendants d'une énergie en provenance
d'une structure privée ce important sa
peau
oui je crois qu'effectivement c'est très
important c'est à dire que la lusine du
galion c'est la seule usine en
martinique être énergétiquement
indépendante
compte tenu du fait qu'elle avait une
chaudière qui produisait de la matière
énergétique pour la la production de son
sucre c'est la cl et indépendant bon
maintenant si on leur accorde à la la
centrale thermique albi au mât aile sera
dépendant que cette centrale peut y
avoir des accords qui puisse garantir
que quel que soit ce qui arrive
l'énergie arrivera quand même tout à
fait il peut y avoir des accords qui
lient meure pour qu'il y ait rien à nous
rien ne nous fait peur je vous rappelle
que le président du conseil exécutif et
moi même nous étions d'accord pour que
cette seule solution je ne suis pas un
fervent de la centrale thermique albi
ioma rassurez vous un mot je ne suis pas
le super défenseur de la centrale
biomasse mais compte tenu du fait que
nous avons reçues écoutez bien nous
avons reçu un rapport de la des halles
où il ya eu une inspection le 25 juillet
et le 26 septembre 2017 nous avons reçu
un courrier du préfet nous demandant
sous contrôle de la dncg va de la
responsabilité du directeur de l'adn et
ensuite une responsabilité du préfet qui
nous demande de mettre aux normes
contenues du fait de nombreuses avaries
contenu également du fait que la
chaudière n'était pas aux normes
environnementales
mais le mans de l'ept met dans chaque à
ses responsabilités y compris le
directeur de la scène du galion y
compris le président compte tenu des
possibilités de mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui
le conseil d'administration de la sem
avait demandé la fermeture de cette
chaudière
donc c'est pourquoi les gens puissent
bien
comprendre pourquoi le conseil
d'administration a pris la décision
avait pris la décision de la fermeture
mais en fait l'important ce qui est
surtout très important c'est qu'il y ait
une campagne sucrière
ouais en 2018 alors cette troisième
option la réparation brusquement
brusquement sorti de votre chapeau ou
richard barthélemy en coûte route de
mons à propos de l'opposition plénière
de la cité valencienne un coup de rabot
sur une structure vieille de près de 30
ans qui n'en peut plus et qui est au
bord de la catastrophe industrielle
vous êtes prêt à prendre cette
responsabilité alors écoutez bien venez
de dire quelque chose qui me gêne un
petit peu quand on me chabot mais mais
oui oui quand mes amis politiques ont
montré leur opposition puisque nous
avons fait une réunion de la majorité
ils ont montré leur opposition à la au
raccordement de la scène du galion à la
centrale thermique albi au mas je leur
ai dit bon il faut absolument que l'on
trouve une solution alternative
donc ils ont trouvé une solution
alternative il y a deux ingénieurs qui
sont venus et qui ont visité la
chaudière au galion et qui ont dit qu'il
est possible qu'il est possible de
réparer la chaudière je rappelle qu'il y
a en martinique de grosses entreprises
qui ont une chaudière il ya une
chaudière d'ailleurs qui a une très très
grosse entreprise qui a une chaudière
qui a 47 ans et qui est un excellent
état donc il est possible de réparer la
chaudière
le problème qui se pose ce sont des
problèmes de délais de délai juste assez
khalid vous le connaissez très bien très
le président de la sica canyons des
membres il est membre du conseil d'ami
sera si l'administrateur la séance
d'hier lorsque nous l'avions nous
l'avons interrogé au lendemain de ce
vote des élus prg sursis il s'est quand
même dit surpris surpris de cette option
réparation il ne veut pas prendre parti
sur gauche mal bio m'a acheté nouvelle
chaude altéra mais il se dit quand même
que
cette décision qui venait de vous les
chars d'artillerie jeter un discrédit
sur l'ensemble du conseil
d'administration sur l'ensemble des
techniciens du galion qui disent ce sera
plus possible
vous parlez de richard bach en télé je
n'ai aucun pouvoir monsieur viol temps
je fonctionne en fonction des goûts
résolution qui sont prises au conseil
d'administration de la sem du gaz non
bâti qu absolument et en fonction des
délibérations de là que je l'actionnaire
majorité acquis est la ctm danser en
fonction des délibérations fonction d'un
certain nombre de décisions qui sont
prises que moi je fonctionne donc sow
était pour moi tout seul je vous
rappelle que j'étais pour cette option
de raccordement de la scène du raid
marie-jeanne partout comme alfred
marie-jeanne raccordement et a su de
loin de dire c'était me semble-t-il la
seule solution lalalala se faisant fi
brusquement d'un revers de main de ces
options de son opinion qu'il avait
affichée au préalable haute avant tout à
fait c'est à dire que vous venez de le
dire moi je suis un homme pragmatique
alfred marie-jeanne aussi est un homme
pragmatique et nouma les nouvelles
brochet pense que c'est la solution
aussi bas c'est la seule solution
possible est justement voiliers et les
sur les réseaux sociaux on apparaissait
déjà comme des presque des ridicules
voilà lyon pathé la lbu au mahb rezaï
d'akobo i'll be home à voyez donc on est
d'avoir bien
certaines personnes de l'opposition
rigoler voilà maintenant que vous
comprenez donc ça c'est toujours
réparation finalement richard martelly
d'un point de vue politique ce n'est pas
un tour de passe-passe pour sauver le
soldat marie jeunes qui avaient affiché
notre une opinion un moment et puis qui
aujourd'hui serait sur le point de
changer
non non ce n'est pas un tour de
passe-passe vous sauver le soldat marc
gène son tour de passe-passe vous sauver
le soldat galliot c'est plutôt ça ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas du tout ça donc
il faut bien comprendre que nous sommes
dans une situation d'urgence où il faut
effectivement tout fait pour que la
scène du galion du savoir
non seulement ça sucre au bible c'est la
seule sucrerie de la jeune dit pouvoir y
est je ne dis pas la dernière souris
jeudi la seule et l'unique sucrerie du
pays et martinique donc il nous faut
tout faire pour que la sucrerie de
galère fonctionne la débauche cette
histoire du galion ses tergiversations
sa fille quand même très mauvais genre
au moment où la filière sucre rhum doit
livrer une bataille sur les quotas
d'exportation plein arbitrage par paris
sur ses quotas d'exportation ce avec une
petite guéguerre avec la guadeloupe
ça fait pas mauvais genre tout ça oui je
vais revenir sur ça mais juste une
présence une reste je suis juste une
précision de 2010 à 2015 tous les devis
de réparation de la chaudière notamment
des tubes 2e millions d'euros ont été
faits en 2013 et rien n'a été fait pour
la réparation
donc moi je dis que ce n'était pas moi
qui était l'entraîneur voir à quoi ça
sert timide ancienne équipe de légers
merci merci monsieur non je résume votre
pensée puisque vous l'aviez déjà annoncé
le d'histoire en plénière mais je
reviens la question cette histoire ses
tergiversations autour du galion ça fait
mauvais genre auprès des abbés des
instances dirigeantes à bercy qui sont
entrés d'arbitrer sur ces questions de
quotas de rome dessus contre la
guadeloupe et la martinique
oui alors s'agissant des quotas des
soupes à les quotas de rome ce sont les
contingents des contingents les
contingents il y a
sur l'ensemble des départements
d'outre-mer je crois 120 mille
hectolitres d'alcool pur à chapet et
l'europe et l'état français autorise
d'augmenter les contingents à 20% et
compte tenu du fait que en fait que nous
bénéficions d'une fiscalité réduite
n'est pas négligeable et donc la
guadeloupe on veut 25% sur ses 20% et
veut laisser que 15% la montée n'est
qu'alors qu'il y a vingt ans la
martinique a fait le choix du rhum
agricole ont l'air bien croyez ça on l'a
expliqué doc sommes justement c'est le
ferrière de l'extérieur donnent
l'impression ne pas savoir ce que nous
voulons pour tout ce qui se fait autour
de la production de kay de cana oui mais
attendez mais écoutez moi je crois que
la martinique
je viens vous dire qu'elle avait fait ce
choix là oui elle avait pas fait le
choix du sucre elle avait seulement fait
le choix du roi et de la banane à
l'époque ça remonte à plus de vingt ans
oui mais l'état et la nation autour du
gal de risque de déséquilibre east
cet ensemble planteurs distille tout à
fait galion s'il la scène du galion
c'est là c'est le moteur de la filière
canne
si la scène du galion doit disparaître
c'est toute la filière qui risque de
s'écrouler à vous en avez conscience
conscience oui je les ai déjà dit oui
j'en ai conscience
il faut pas souhaiter ça monsieur je ne
suis pas à ma desheng à bercy auprès des
gouvernements alors son contrat
concernant les contingents les six
parlementaires martiniquais ont signé un
accord pour intervenir auprès des auprès
des gouvernements français d'une part et
la chance que nous avons c'est qu'aucun
parlementaire guadeloupéen n'a encore
n'a encore mis le nez dans cette affaire
donc on a encore une chance de pouvoir
récupérer nos nos vins pause merci
beaucoup
richard berry on rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'assemblée rien que tout à
l'heure vous allez à la rencontre du
personnel du galion qui a peur de ce qui
peut se passer dans cette filière bonne
journée merci monsieur auld
[Musique]